hello everyone on freecodecamp today
wanting to learn about
low code now if you're looking to spin
up apps fast with out of the box ui
component
this is the course for you my name is
anya and i'm a software developer
youtube tutorial creator and your video
instructor for this low
code course in this course you will
learn all about local solutions by
building three financial apps
these apps will be number one a trade
dashboard for brokers to log their
trades as well as
track their commissions as well as
communicate with their back offices via
an integrated
message sender thanks to slack api
number two is going to be a crypto
dashboard using coin api
service to get live prices as well as
utilizing twilio's api to send text
messages to your friends
or family about any changes you see
instantly
and three an invoice tracker that
communicates with an external database
using graphql api
and allows you to embed instructional
videos for those using it
now these three apps might sound
intimidating to you if you are not
super well versed in using apis and
building up front ends for them
but the whole point of low code
solutions is that it takes the pain out
of doing both
of these things think of low code as
platforms that essentially give you all
the ui components you need
so for example tables graphs text boxes
you name it
and then also give the option to
integrate them using pre-configured
inputs for apis
this type of solution is perfect for
personal trackers on your finances
in-house apps that need to be spun up
quickly or perhaps
proof of concept prototypes looking for
investment
and that is only the tip of the iceberg
stick around to the end of the tutorial
for the where to go next section to see
what other things
you can build so that leads me nicely
into what exactly we are going to be
covering in this course
in this course we will look at low code
versus
note code setting up retool compatible
integrations
building a trade dashboard building a
crypto dashboard
building an invoice tracker and of
course where to go next
now the only prerequisite i ask of you
before starting is to have a basic
understanding of how apis work before
starting this course
or if you don't know what apis are but
are feeling up to it please do have a go
at following along anyway
i will be taking things super slow and
covering everything as we go
to make this course as accessible to as
many people as
possible okay so what are we waiting for
let's do it as always please do hit that
sub button as it really does help out
this channel
and providing you with free courses and
tutorials your support is really what
makes preeco camp what it is
today let's start with exactly what low
code is
low code in the least amount of words is
a way for developers to create
applications quick with minimal effort
most low code platforms allow developers
to drag
and drop visual blocks of existing code
into a workflow to create
any application they wish the main
advantages of low code apart from it
being a huge time saver
is that a developer can just jump right
in to create an app in a business you
don't have to learn what frameworks they
are using
how they like to work you don't need to
create a github account even
or create any components and the best
part for me
is that you don't have to write any
tests for them either
now that we have covered low code how is
that different to
no code well as the name would suggest
no code solutions are for those with
zero coding knowledge at all
simply drag and drop things to create an
app and that's it
and whilst you might be like oh well why
do i just use that
whilst no code solutions can be pretty
powerful they are often quite limiting
especially when it comes to wanting to
integrate databases
in addition to this it can result in
apps being created without the proper
expertise and needed to maintain them
so if something goes wrong for example
or needs to be changed
that is going to be an issue and not to
mention security concerns and compliance
issues that could result from that
too all in all a no-code solution was
perfect for building
some things so think like personal
projects that don't rely on databases
can end up being a huge headache further
down the line when used in a
professional
setting for this tutorial we are going
to be using a tool
called retool so here's a tool we're
going to use it is free to use
on a trial basis and the best part about
it is that it comes with all of these
fantastic integrations already done
for us so there really is a lot i'm
going to be trying to cover the main
ones that i use
on a day-to-day basis in this tutorial
so these ones
right here okay so i hope you're excited
let's do it
okay so let's get to creating our first
app which is going to be a trades
dashboard using the
google sheets api so here's what your
dashboard
should look like once you have signed up
to retool
the low code platform and i am just
going to create a
new app by actually adding a resource
first so i'm just going to gravitate to
the resources
tab we're going to start off by
connecting the resource that we need in
this case it's of course going to be
a google sheet so let's just gravitate
to the resources and i am going to not
use the sample google sheets i'm going
to create a new resource
select google sheets and i'm just going
to choose
to call it let's just call it trades for
now
please make sure to select the read and
write if you plan on adding data from
your app
to the google sheet if you don't want to
just want to read the data but you want
it to be
interactive make sure that this read and
write
option is selected and
there we go we of course need to
authorize
our retool to talking to our google
sheets so
i'm just going to go ahead and do that
by clicking authorize
and going through these steps okay
wonderful
so now we have connected retool
to our personal google sheets by
allowing a retool to speak to our
google drive essentially so that is
done now let's get to creating a new app
with this resource so i'm just going to
click
create a new app now and
let's go ahead and name it so i'm going
to call it trades
dashboard okay so pretty easy
trades dashboard if i can only spell
trades dashboard
okay and there we go
this is our app it's got some default
stuff here but don't worry
let's actually maybe get rid of all this
for now so i'm just going to delete the
default query that this comes with
and make a new query
okay so here we are here's essentially a
list of all the resources
so all the resources when we were just
on the resource tab
including the new resource we made
called
traits so i'm just going to select
that one okay
so now that we have that resource i'm
just gonna maybe
make this a little bit bigger
please make sure the action type is read
data from a spreadsheet
so because we want to be you know
reading the data from our spreadsheet
and of course we need to tell the
platform
which spreadsheet we want from our
google
docs so i know that my spreadsheet is
called
trades so i'm just going to select that
but you will see
all your google sheets essentially here
as an option
okay and wonderful if i run
this query you will actually see a
preview of all the
data so that is really useful and the
next thing i want to do
is actually get that showing on a table
so before we do that i'm just going to
delete this table
and i'm actually going to rename this
query to
trades or perhaps get trades that's
a bit better in terms of readability so
get trades
and then i am just going to drag in
a table now once you've
done this you will see the table
actually uses the data from get trade so
that was really simple we really didn't
need to do
much that is because we are currently on
the get trades query okay so it's
automagically using that data for us
to create this wonderful table based on
the
query data okay
so this looks pretty simple right all
we've done is drag a table
making sure that we are on the get
trades query as we do it
now i'm going to show you this little
left sidebar as it's super
useful i think it's uh very powerful
when it comes
to dealing with more complex um
i guess results and if we
now look here at the queries and
transformers you will see the get
trade query of course but you will also
see how this data is returned
so you will see the data comes as an
array of
objects okay and that is what we are
using to essentially create
the table it is something that i'm
probably more comfortable
using in terms of coding so it can be
really useful to you
if you are a dev that is that prefers to
work in this type of way
okay i think let's move on
the next thing i'm going to show you is
actually how to
personalize some of these uh
columns so there's a lot we can do with
these columns
for example let's select the first
one now say i know this
column i want it to
come in the format of dates and i want
it to be more
readable i can simply select the column
type to be a date
and you will see how the timestamp has
now
changed to have the month day
and year so that's just been formatted
for me
we can of course do other things we can
filter them so if you click on the
column
it will filter and then you can also do
things
such as you know change the background
color
so i can simply select a column and type
in the color red
of course you can use hex codes
and rgb as well or you can simply type
the term red
the platform is pretty intuitive when it
comes to
that another thing that you
can do is let's maybe look at the
price so if i click on the price
column i can make sure that this is
showing up in us dollars simply by
selecting the
us dollar option and we can do the same
for commission so once again i'm just
going to click on the commission
usd column
and from the column type i'm just going
to make that
show up in dollars too
great so there are a few different
styles you can run with i'm just gonna
space this out so it's a bit more
readable for us
there we go okay and
wonderful now another super useful thing
you can
do is not only create tables from your
data but also create graphs
super easily so i'm talking pie charts
bar charts anything you really
wish so to do this i'm actually just
going to click
off the table and using the same query
so making sure you are still on the
get trades query i'm just going to drag
in
a bar chart
so here we go i've just dragged one in
i'm just gonna move it around
okay so there we go
and now so you can see the x-axis value
is the
timestamp and i can also
change this around to make more sense so
i'm just going to
hide some of these i'm gonna hide these
three
in order to make the x-axis the
timestamp and the y-axis
the commission in us dollars
okay so there we go we can see it of
course it's very
small just because we have that very
large commission one on that
let's just make it a little bit darker
so you can see it and
wonderful so we've now plotted
essentially
the amount of commission that is made
by day okay and it was really
painless so that is another thing you
can do
with the data that we are getting from
the get trades
query okay
i'm just going to show you how to create
another chart
um this time i'm just going to move this
around a little bit
this time let's make a pie chart so once
again all i'm gonna have to do is change
the data sets this time i'm just gonna
have
the commission by us dollars and i want
to do it by
broker so to do this i would simply get
the value labels
and select broker and there we go
now we can see exactly how much each
broker is making what percentage of the
pie for the desk
they are making and of course we can
change the colors
around a bit too so let's go ahead and
do that
okay wonderful this is really
interactive you can interact with pieces
of the pie
as well all of these components come not
just visually
but also with a bunch of extra cool
features too
so it really is quite advanced in terms
of handling
uh data and transforming it into graphs
okay i'm just going to show you one more
example that we can do that would really
fit
this trade dashboard so i'm just going
to use
the bar chart again for this
and this time i'm going to actually
select the x axis to be the broker
okay so we know what percentage of the
pie each broker is making
this time i want to see exactly how much
uh commission
the broker is making okay so i can see
that annie glover has made around 25k
and she's made around 70
for the desk okay 70 of the total for
the desk
wonderful okay so this is looking pretty
good and all just from one google sheet
at the moment the next thing i am
actually going to do
is show you how you can now
add more data to the google sheet
okay so we're displaying the data but we
want to not only read the data we want
to write data to
and to do this i want to be able to add
a trade
but from the platform okay
hopefully that makes sense let's
carry on so to do this i'm actually
going to
use a modal so let's just go ahead and
select
the modal component and i'm going to
just drag it
up here okay
for the button text i'm actually going
to change this to
add a trade and then
let's just change the button color let's
go with a
red and yeah okay
now that we have the pop-up working the
first thing i want to do is actually
make this a form because we're going to
have to submit the form
so i'm just going to drag in the form
component
just like so okay
so that is done we have created a form
and now it's going to make this a bit
smaller now we're gonna have to drag in
things into our form
um okay
so the first thing i'm gonna do is
actually just drag in some
text because this is where we're gonna
want to give some information about
what kind of data goes into our
trade essentially so i'm just going to
drag in some
text to let the user know that this is
for a ticket
and this is going to be the buy side
okay so
here's the text the asterisks on the
text mean that this is going to be
in bold i'm just going to get rid of
this and right
by side and then also get rid of the
emoji
and perhaps let's make the background
green you can apply custom
styling i will be showing you how to do
this but for now just
stick with me this is something that
i'll be showing you how to do
later okay so we have
the buy side the next thing we're going
to do is
just make the cell side 2 while we're
here
so i'm just going to drag in another
text component
and i'm just going to edit this to say
cell side
and also get rid of the emoji and once
again let's make the background red
you'll notice the text is changing to be
white to make this more readable
that is a feature that is built into the
low code platform however if you want to
change this as mentioned
the option to add your own custom css
will also be
available to you i'll show you how to do
this
okay now we have the bar spy side and
the cell side
the first thing you want to do is start
putting in some input
so we have you know what is
corresponding to the google sheet
so that means uh products and entity
a timestamp the volume and so on so the
first thing we do is just put in a text
input like
so okay i can also choose to position
the writing at the top
if i want and i'm just going to give
this a label of
entity like so
i can also make this a required field so
just by ticking this
little text box right here okay
and that is done we have created our
first input this input is going to be
for the
entity that is going to have made the
trade
now let's actually create a second one
because
obviously i'm going to have a buy side
and a cell side each one need an entity
so once again i'm just going to make
this go to the top
instead of going to the left and i'm
going to make this
a required field
wonderful so now that we have an entity
for the buy
side and an entity for the sell side the
next thing i'm going to do
is actually have something for the
product because we're going to have to
choose
what kind of product this is to go on
our table
so i'm going to choose to make this a
drop down just so people can't enter
whatever they wish
so i'm going to search for the drop down
option
and once again when we are here
we have a label and then we also have
the values
so at the moment the values that appear
are 1 two and three
i want this to be products so i'm just
gonna put in some
standard uh products that you would see
um if you're trading the
uh brent dubai crude so
i'm just going to put some in here for
now
this is of course just for demonstration
purposes
you can make this whatever you want
making sure it's an array of strings
separated by commas okay
so we have august september october
november
december i'm just gonna copy all of that
and i'm just going to paste it
and instead of rent i'm going to change
this
to dubai first line crude
okay wonderful and then perhaps let's
have just some straight up futures
so
okay
i'm just going to change this from brent
fastline to brent
crude future
okay i mean yeah that's fine
um again this is just for you know
demonstration purposes
so now if i go here i can select a
product
that is only from that list
so this is how you would do that i'm
just going to change this label to be
product as well
and make this a required field
okay wonderful so now that is done
and i've shown you how you can do that
of course you can make your own this is
just for demonstration purposes um
let's actually do it for the other side
too
it's going to check this works so it is
required field
if i don't pick one yes a red thing
shows up
okay now that we have done that i'm just
going to stick it on the other side
too and there we go
okay wonderful i mean i think this is
pretty neat
if i was still working this sort of
thing would be extremely useful
and extremely time saving when it came
to
you know keeping track of your traits so
the next thing we'll do is
actually use a number input this time to
put
in the price of the product that was
traded
so i'm just going to drag in a number
input
and i'm just going to change the label
to be price
us dollars okay
price us dollars and then just want to
put out the top
oh let's make it required field as well
while we're here
i'm just gonna copy it and put it on the
other
side too okay
so that is looking quite good we've got
some number inputs i'm just gonna copy
again
um because we also need to put in
the volume traded so i'm just going to
use another number input for this
the volume in kb and copy it to the
other side
to the the sell side too because you
know someone's buying
this and someone's selling
this okay
i'm just going to make this a little bit
bigger so it's easier to work with and
you can see a little bit better
and there we go so now we've copied it
we have two things for the volume uh
we can also make sure that this
is in currency so i'm just going to
format this as
currency so great that makes a lot more
sense so now we know that whatever is
being put into here will be
the format of a currency and for this
one
we're not really going to do anything at
the moment
okay now i'm just going to copy this
again as we want another
input for the commission rate so let's
change the label to commission
rate and once again i am just going to
copy this using the copy command on my
keyboard
and move it to the cell set okay so now
each side has pretty much the same on it
and of course i'm just going to change
this to be top positions for all of them
just because i think it's a lot neater
and we can actually see what is on each
label
for this one it's not actually letting
me go to the top
so i mean we could just get rid of the
label maybe let's do that
i guess we don't need it if we can have
um
you know like a placeholder so
yeah maybe let's do that i'm just going
to work on how you can see this a little
bit better
so i'm just actually going to
move this down here okay wonderful so
that is
i think that's a lot better for this
video now you can see everything
okay so we've got a bunch of stuff we're
still not done yet
i still need to i guess calculate
the exact amount commission made and
which broker
made it so to do this i'm actually going
to use
a statistic
i'm just going to search for statistic
and then just drag it and drop it
here there we go
great i'm just going to change this to
be the title
of commission i'm going to do a little
calculation
here okay and just display it to the
user as well as use this to put
into our google sheet later
so we've called this commission um
okay i'm actually gonna use oops i have
misspoke commission okay commission has
two m's and two s's so commission
commission uh okay
okay i think that's fine right to get
the commission
i'm actually going to have to do a bit
of a calculation so
let's do that in the value i'm going to
get up these syntax for retail so we
need these two curly braces like so
and i'm going to grab whatever
is the number input
to that's right value so whatever i put
into there
multiply by a thousand and then also
multiplied by the
commission rate so commission rate
value so whatever i put in that
multiplied by the
prop hold on that should be volume so
what is this
yeah okay whatever the volume is
multiplied by the commission
i'm just going to change this to a four
okay and that should be the value
so now let's test it out if i just fill
these in let's do that now
okay so volume multiply by commission
rate and that will give me the
commission that i have made
on this side of the ticket okay so this
is cool i'm essentially just generating
a number based on the inputs
that i've been put in and let's just do
the same on the other side
so i'm just going to copy this using the
copy command on my keyboard
and i'm just going to change this here
to be number input
3 and the commission rate for the buy
side
okay so just change out these numbers
and now i'm just going to
test this out so let's put in the
volume um let's do
no 100
kb and make the course commission rate
0.05
and great that gives me 500.
not lbs though um let's just make it we
don't need a suffix
great so nearly
that the next thing that i want to do
for this ticket so that's quite cool
right we've sort of um
at least done one input uh based
on some calculations so we don't have to
do that
this um usually when i was a broker we
would have to you know like do the
calculation in our head or use a
calculator
and this way would just calculate that
commission for us
okay so we've got everything and the
last thing i want to do is actually
um pass through which broker did this
trade
so for this as we have you know like a
set a set amount of brokers that are
working on this desk
i'm actually going to use a drop down
so i'm just going to select the drop
down um i'm going to
get rid of the label okay
because we can just have
uh we can have a placeholder instead so
select
broker and we're actually meant to do
that for above as well so let's do that
again for the i'm going to get rid of
the label and just put
you know like select product and
again for this side to select
products and get rid of the label okay
cool okay right now we don't want the
brokers be one two and three
right this is just default values we
want it to look like this
so i'm going to change the values and
who are our workers well we've got annie
glover
we have david astro
we have jeremy lane
and we have sammy
yeah cool that's it um wonderful and
once again i'm just gonna use my copy
command
to copy this and make another one for
the bicep
okay great so this is looking good
we have now completed our module we have
now completed a way for us to i'm just
gonna
maybe move this out a little bit better
to make it look nicer
but we have now essentially completed a
way to add trades
to our table by using this little pop-up
model with required fields
okay the next thing we need to do is
actually make something happen if we
click
submit so at the moment obviously
nothing happens
and all the fields are required are
giving us error messages
i need to essentially make a new query
that instead of
getting trades we'll add a trade
to our table so to do this
i'm going to go back here create new
uh just select the new resource query
and let's just rename this to add trade
great making sure the resource is still
the
trades list and then
um what i need to do is make the
action type and of course choose a
spreadsheet
so this spreadsheet was trades
let's do that for our trade so select a
sheet
trades and then
[Music]
okay this is looking good
and then i need to change the action
type
so the action type i want to be append
data to spreadsheet
okay because we want to add a new
essentially line to
our spreadsheet so this is how we would
do it and the
values to append so this is going to be
an array and we need to add an
array of objects just like we saw in the
left sidebar we need to keep these
structure the same
so to this um to this array
my first object is going to be a
timestamp
just like in our table and for the time
stamp the value
is going to be just today's date so this
is a bit of javascript i'm using
a date object to essentially add
today's exact date whenever we add a
trade to the dashboard which will then
be sent
to our google sheet okay
so new date is going to be the timestamp
okay if you know javascript um you know
what this will return
if you don't please do have a google of
the date
object and let's carry
on so i'm just going to make sure this
is formatted correctly
um cool the next thing that we need to
add is the
entity and the entity
let's do the uh let's do the buy
side first hold on this is not
something's wrong here
i don't see why this should be wrong
maybe let's just carry on and
it will update okay so let's focus on
the buy
side first we're going to add the buy
side first and then the cell side so
two lines to our spreadsheet essentially
so the entity is going to be the
first text input component that we used
so up here the entity is text input 1
because we're doing the buy
side first we're adding the buy side
trade to our dashboard
text input one value
okay so we've got the entity the next
thing we're going to do
is product so it's really easy we're
literally just
finding the component on our dashboard
and using its
value the next thing i'm going to do is
actually need a direction too so we said
there's going to be by side i can just
hard code this
uh to be by side because we don't need
to select a direction
we should know that you know like if
it's under the buy side the green
title this is going to be a buy side
trip
next let's add the product so just like
we found the other component this time
i'm going to find the drop down
which is called select one if we hover
over it it's the bit in the blue
and i'm going to get the value of that
the next thing i'm going to add is the
price in u.s dollars
making sure by the way that um these
what i'm
the uh keys are the same as the
headers of our um columns
in our google sheet uh table
and the price usd is gonna be once again
let's just hover over it
and we're gonna get the value of
whatever we put in this
number input okay hopefully this is
making
sense the more we go along
the next thing we do is the volume kb
so the volume kb
is going to be well let's have a look at
what component
is and it's text input number input
three sorry
so number input three value
so great uh
next we need to do the
commission rate
so i'm just going to do commission rates
hold on how did i for commission because
i've been making loads of mistakes
commission oops we have misspelled
commission here
so commission here has a one so for the
sake of it here i'm just gonna
spell it the way i wrote it in my table
because as i mentioned it has to be
exact has to be the same spelling
otherwise this will not
work so commission rate i'll change it
later but just
bear with me for now um sometimes i do
think making mistakes like this
is the easiest way of understanding how
this is all working
hopefully you see now that why this
needs to be exact because
it needs to be exactly the same as the
column
column title like so commissions but
with one m
okay so we're gonna put what are we
gonna put
in this column where we're gonna put the
what is this number input five value
so number input five values whatever i
put
in this input that is going to be my
commission rate
great the next thing we need to do is
get the commission usd which i've
misspelled here again and i clearly
wasn't having a very good day with this
word
commission's dealt with with um 2ms and
1s
this time in us dollars
i promise i will fix this commission u.s
dollars is going to be well we know this
is going to be the statistic
right it's going to be the thing that we
figured out so i'm going to go into
statistic and the statistic 2
um so let's select statistic two and
once again value
bit and the last thing we should do is
just put the broker that did it
so broker and then
we need to go into the drop down i
believe was a drop down
but let's just double check maybe um
hold on it wasn't called dropped and was
it dropdown value
is not defined okay so that doesn't
exist here
um let's just have a look ah okay fine
select
for is not called drop down select full
value
wonderful so now we have done everything
for the buy side
if we round this it should essentially
add a row to our table
but we need the cell slide too so
okay cell size i'm just going to copy
all of this that we've done so far
and we now need to adjust it for this
cell side
so i'm going to copy it paste it and now
i'm just going to change these to be
this number direction is going to be
sell
product is going to be select
2 price usd is going to be number input
2 volume kb is going to be number input
4 um this is going to be
statistic one and
select three okay
great so we've done it i'm gonna
save this get rid of this comma we don't
need to save this
and okay i'm just gonna
now fix this because you know like it's
better to have everything correct
okay so we've changed that um in here
i'm gonna get the trades again
just to see if that has worked okay so
commission rate commission rate good
it's messed up with our graphs but we'll
fix that a bit later
okay so now that we've fixed the
spilling commission
um commission rate commission rate
we need to hook up our submit button
so to do this we are going to have to
create our first event handler
if i click on the submit button an event
event has actually been generated for us
so i'm just going to click here to show
you what is going to happen
is i'm going to run the query add trade
it's selected add trade because we are
currently on that query
and on submit i'm going to
add a trade so on submit essentially i'm
going to run this query i'm going to run
the add
trade query okay as soon as i press the
submit button
great so that is looking good i can also
add confetti
just for fun um wee confetti
so that you know like when i press the
submit confetti
gets thrown as well and another thing i
could do is also
rerun the get trades query so the
previous query where to get all the
trades i can run that query so after we
added the trade to the bottom two we can
run the get
query get trades query again okay
so that we can actually see them in the
browser itself
so that is looking good i think let's
test it out
so let's just make sure that we into all
of these i'm going to put test
test september
september i'm just making this up really
i don't really know what september brent
first line
uh price is at the moment let's say 65
55.
and it's also put yeah 80 44. um
make this up just fine fine
just put in some brokers and click
submit woo and confetti we have run the
add
trades query um we're getting some
errors why is it
red it hasn't been added why is this
let's have a deeper dive into this
okay so that has not been added
it should appear at the bottom here it
has not
why is this happening
got it don't want that at the moment
let's go back in here and have a look
again at what
values we're appending um okay we've got
an error message
commission ah we did not we did not
correct commission spelling here
okay fine fair enough there we go
these error uh messages are super handy
i mean already i know why this has not
worked
and click save okay so let's try it
again
add trade submit
okay no errors now let's have
a look so that has not been added
to the bottom but let's see if it's been
added
to my google sheets and it has
wonderful so we've added these trades
this is
working woo we've added the two new
trades
we've broken a few things along the way
like the bar charts but don't worry it's
a step-by-step process
um the get queries did not get run
though so sorry the get trade query did
not get run however
um so if i actually manually run this
you will see the new trades
so why is this not working
let's try again
it could just be a bit too slow as in
we're adding and then we're getting but
the get is running
before the out trade um
no this seems to be okay okay well
there's another way to do this which is
actually probably better
uh we can also i'm just gonna change
this for now
i think that big volume wasn't great
okay so we can we
um obviously that's
oh that time no it didn't work no okay
so we can do this another way i can
actually make this run after the query
runs
after the add trade query runs so
to do this i would
just click on the add trades query again
and
on a success trigger so after this query
runs
get the trades okay so this is actually
a bit more foolproof
and let's check it out add a trade
and then let's just change it so we can
see a little bit of a difference
i'm going to call this test new
and test new click submit
okay let's see if that has worked
so now let's go to the last page and
wonderful
okay that has worked we have done it
we've added a new trade and it's
showing on our dashboard amazing
i'm really pleased with how this is
looking
so cool we've done this um i'm just
going to change this to add a new trade
okay and now let's also
based on everything we have learnt we're
gonna do a bit of repetition
and just make another model using
everything that we have learnt
so far so i'm doing this you know for
muscle memory
and also to make it a lot more realistic
and the sort of trade dashboard that you
would see
at a brokerage because you don't only
have
uh trades that have two sides who are
buying sell side
you can also have someone just selling
some brent futures online
so i'm going to create a new pop-up
module
very similar to this one but this time
it's going to be a custom trade
uh once again it's just a pop-up model
maybe let's call this
custom add custom trade
and then let's make it green
okay and this time i am going to allow
the person to select a direction and
it's only going to be
uh you know like not double side it's
going to be one side
so once again i'm going to
well actually we don't really have to
make this
um okay so let's just make this
create a custom trade
get rid of the emoji using the asterisks
to make this bold
and then let's make it yellow because
yellow is quite a neutral color
there we go okay
let's do it the first thing i'm going to
do is just drop in an input
this input is going to be a just a text
input with a tray direction
which we're going to enter either by or
cell the next
thing i'm going to do is just put
another text input
this time it's going to be for the
entity so let's change this up to be
entity
and let's put up some placeholder text
of enter
company uh name okay
so name there we go just make a capital
and now we've got the trade direction
got the entity
this time let's grab a drop down for the
product so this is going to be for what
kind of product we want
to select essentially label it as
product and the drop down well i've
already done this
so once again i'm just going to get an
array of strings
separated by commas okay so that is how
we put in
values so there we go we've done it we
put an array of strings
separated by commas to signify the
items in our dropdown the next thing
we'll do is actually put a number
input so let's drag that in here and
give it the label of price usd
and i'm actually going to format this to
be currency
so that we can only put in numbers that
have a currency
format the next thing i'm going to do is
just
copy this using the copy command
and i am going to use this to have my
volume in kb
um unformatted so just a standard format
once we have that and once again just
going to use my command to copy
and paste another number input
this time however the label is going to
say commission
rate because that is where i'm going to
put the number value for my commission
rate and now that we have that if you
remember the next thing we did is
actually use the statistic
component so i'm dragging that in there
and dropping it in here
and we are going to essentially use this
to calculate
our commission so the total commission
for this ticket
based on so we need to use the syntax
the two curry braces
to pick out an element in this case it's
number input eight
and it's value okay so dot value
whatever the value of that input is
multiplied by a thousand and multiplied
by the commission
rate which is number input nines value
that is how i
have chosen to calculate my commission
for this ticket
okay so let's just check this out i'm
going to put volume 100 kb
and commission rate 0.05
and number 100 multiplied
by 1000 multiplied by 0.005
indeed gives me 500 and the format of
that is
dollars so this is looking good it's
calculating it correctly
everything's looking wonderful the next
thing i'm going to do is actually use
another
drop down so if you remember from the
previous
model we did we actually had a drop down
for the
brokers so once again i'm just going to
put broker
and once again i'm just going to go back
and copy it just to make it exactly the
same
because we need to paste in the broker
options
and once again it's an array of strings
followed by commas to essentially split
them out as individual
items okay so we've done that
we've done everything here the next
thing we need to do ah we didn't put it
in the form
so let's go ahead and do that
put in the form and then let's just
whack all these things
in so just move them in we could have
not really you don't have to make this a
form you can just
put a bus in but this way is
a better practice um essentially if you
did the button you could have just
done the same thing you know attach an
uh event to it so like a trigger
but we're not going to okay this
is a much better way of doing this so
there's our form
now let's hook up the submit button
so i'm just going to click on the submit
button and of course we need an event
handler for this so here we go
i'm going to say that if we submit the
button
i want to run the query add trade and i
want that
to trigger however
this won't make sense right because the
ad
trade query will trigger the other
modal because we've picked out all the
different components
for this okay the added trade even if i
fill
all these things out we'll essentially
use the not the custom trade options but
the previous model that we built
this is not correct we need to build
a new query so once again i'm going to
click
new resource and once again let's rename
this
i'm going to rename this to add custom
trade
it's going to be pretty much the same as
our trade so the spreadsheet we need for
this is trades
and here action type i'm going to say
append
data to a spreadsheet so just like add
trade essentially oops let's save this
save just like add trade however the
only difference is
the values to append will be different
but we're going to use this as a
template so i'm just going to paste all
this
move this up so you can see it better
i'm going to delete this
uh i guess second row because that was a
second
row and now we're going to append one
row
and let's change these values up a bit
so times some new date that'll be fine
that'd be today's date
entity well i want to grab another text
input this time i want to grab
text input three's value okay that's
because
it's this component that we need to grab
it's text input
oops four actually text input four
okay so i'm just gonna move these around
a little bit text input four
uh it's value that's gonna be the entity
now direction is gonna be
okay we could actually make this
perhaps we should make this something
else text input three
perhaps we should be more strict and say
you know it should just be a buy
or it should just be a cell rather than
someone being able to enter whatever
they want so i'm going to use
uh another option for this that is
available
to us just be a bit more strict i'm
going to use this segmented control
so i'm going to grab that and just work
that in here it really is that easy
and this time um
i'm going to i'm just going to delete
this move everything up again
there we go okay so now we have this
let's put the values as
buy and sell
okay and labels i'm going to put buy and
sell as well okay so there you go
and default value is going to buy
wonderful
now we don't want label
so now i'm going to get the segmented
control
one value
great value wonderful
cool let's carry on product
is gonna be uh select five
the next one's gonna be text input 7 so
once again i'm just going to
be finding out reading off the blue
whenever i hover
over each component that is essentially
the component's name
this is going to be number input 8. this
is going to be number input
nine and then commission rate
that's fine this is going to be
statistic
three so let's change that to a three
and then we just need the broker i
believe so this is a select
just change the number on
that to be a six
wonderful and let's click save
okay let's test it out ah we also need
to of course
make sure that the submit button is
triggering the correct query
so we need to change this to add custom
trade and then once again let's maybe
send some confetti great now if you
remember from the previous thing there's
one more thing we need to do and on
success trigger we need to
get the trades again so they can see the
new trades
in our table wonderful
now let's get to testing this out
okay so let's do it i'm just going to
put in some
oops i'm going to put in i'm just going
to move this down a bit
click add custom trade i'm just going to
put
test custom
trade make this a cell
product and then just put in some random
price
uh volume let's say 200 commission rate
0.05
that is looking like the correct
commission amount and let's make the
broker annie glover
now i'm just going to click submit the
confetti goes off and
there we go we have added our custom
trade
is one line this time i can see it so
the get
trades queries also ran what's this add
custom trade query
has run wonderful
this is looking so fantastic
we've added some we've added a custom
trade we've added
a uh i guess double-sided trade
this is looking great
one more thing to do and that is
integrate our slack channel
okay
uh before we do this let's actually fix
these
as i said when i uh rerun the query and
change
some of the column names this actually
broke
so i'm just going to change these um
let's perhaps give this a title
so commission by percentage that is
meant to be
and this one is meant to be
a daily desk commission obviously
doesn't look like that now but that's
what it's meant to be
and this one
this was meant to be uh this is yeah how
much each broker made
so perhaps let's call it commission
uh in us dollar okay
cool now
so to do this i'm just going to delete
this drag in
a new bar chart
now the x axis at oops we need to make
sure that
is getting the correct query so get
trades
get all the trades data
and now let's make sure that the x and y
axis is correct
so i just want to use uh commission in
us dollars
but let's do the x axis first so
by broker oops
and then we want the commission use
dollars so let's hide these
three wonderful okay so that one is
fixed we still need to fix those
two but perhaps
let's do the slack integration first
okay
so the first thing we're going to do is
just use this
form just like that
let's move this out the way
okay
and let's create a new resource so i'm
just going to create a new
resource this time i'm going to actually
go back
to here and go back to my resources tab
and create a completely
new one and then just use the uh let's
find
slack because this has been
pre-configured for us by retool already
so i'm just going to find it wherever it
is i know it exists there is
okay now what should we call this
resource just for
our own um knowledge in this app i'm
gonna call it slack api
now we need to get a web hook to make
this work so
to do this let's go
to slack an easy way to do is just click
right here click
create a slack web hook and i'm just
going to sign in with google
so i'm just going to click here okay
it looks like you're new to slack create
a new workplace
create a new workplace
what's the name of your company i'm just
going to go ania's
demo next um
what's your team working right now
retail
uh which we call this low code course
great
who do you want to email um let's
let's skip this for now
wonderful and open this in slug so now
if we go to slack
there we go i have created a workspace
essentially
and there's no one in here this is of
course just
for me at the moment now let's get to
hooking this up to our platform
so for this we need a web hook right so
let's get to it this is step one now
step two is the web hook
to integrate the slack channel with my
platform
and just go back here create a web hook
and there we go now that i have a
channel this is a lot easier
choose a channel low code course so all
my
message is going to go here and add a
coming web hooks
so here's my webhook url literally a few
steps to do this super easy
just whack that in there and we don't
want to create a new app so let's go
back to
resources and then back to our
trades dashboard so we've added that new
resource let's carry on
so the first thing i'm going to do is
what should we do first i am going
to just use some text so i'm going to
make a text area this time not a text
input
and then what should we call this
i'm going to call this create message
and then maybe let's get an emoji i'm
going to get a writing emoji for this
clean cute maybe let's make it a little
bit smaller and you can also import
images in here so let's go ahead and
just put
slack's logo in just so everyone knows
what this
is i'm just going to google slack logo
for this
i'm just going to use one that's hosted
online um
just for this tutorial
so i'm just going to copy one from free
social media icons
copy image address
and then just put it
in here like so so there we go
we have our slack logo from the
internet it is hosted online off the
internet we've just got it
next thing i want to do is actually
i'm just going to grab the text again
and this is we're going to display
what we are going to send it's like a
little preview
i'm going to call it slack preview
okay and once again let's
whack in an emoji i'm going to put in a
little speech bubble emoji
okay looking very cute once again the
asterisks are there
to make it the text bold okay
um if i get rid of them that is what it
looks like
okay so with and without the little
asterisks so
now i can use this um
let's make a little container actually
i'm going to put a container in here
to make it a little bit smaller and
move the form up as well because all
these things are in a form
currently let's move that down
and in here let's change the background
perhaps so i can
be really precise with the background or
i could just choose
a pre-made one is up to us okay so there
we go that's a bit lighter now
and in the slight preview i want to
preview what i'm typing
so i'm going to grab the text again
let's make it wider
and this time in the value rather than
just having some text
i am going to use this pre-written piece
of code that i have
okay so this is some pre-written code
this isn't
a coding uh course this
is essentially just some html that i'm
not really going to go through
hopefully you know your html if not
please do
do some googling at this point in time
or you can just
um you know pause this and just take
this from me essentially i've done some
uh custom code okay which you will see
styled in a bit
and i'm going to use the retool syntax
so once again the two curly braces
to get whatever the value of my text
area is
so text area dot value
now this means that whatever i type will
show up in the container
below before we move on i'm going to
show you how to
add some custom css so
to do this you just need to click on
these three dots right here
and click on the scripts thing and
styling
and then just click on the css
part to add custom css to this whole
app so here is my custom css
i'm just going to paste it once again
this is not really a coding course
this is just some custom css to style
the divs
and tags that i previously put in
i'm just going to save that and there
you go the styling has been applied
wonderful now if i actually type some
text
into the create message you will see
that being
previewed in my slack preview
component that i have custom built
great this is looking good let's perhaps
also
change the button color let's make it a
bit more like slack
i'm gonna give it purple awesome
so we've done this and now of course we
need to
hook up the submit button so for this i
need my
i need to make a new query i'm going to
add a new
resource and then i'm going to
essentially search oh we might refresh
this
i need to search for the uh slack
resource that we just created
so here i'm going to go resource and
search for slack api
great so we have the slack api
now we just need to use
our retool syntax to post a message to
the slack channel we chose
so this is the message that's going to
be sent i'm going to write user
current user first name so
this is essentially saying that
whatever's going to be sent to slack is
going to have user dot dot
and well whoever's using it so current
user first name this is going to tell
anya because i'm the current user
uh and then let's have
the message itself so i'm going to go
into the text area again and get the
value
okay so that's our query let's save that
let's also perhaps
um okay so
okay so that's cool if i press submit
at the moment you'll see nothing's
happening because we don't have an event
handler
on submit i need to get the query query
for perhaps let's rename this i'm going
to rename this to send
message now you'll see if i run this
query
there you go that is working
so there we go there's our incoming
message if i run that query that will
work
so i'm just going to type another
message in just to check this is working
let's learn more luggage
okay so now it still likes it so that is
good
everything is working as it should
wonderful okay
uh let's carry on
so this is looking good this is what our
app will look like if we preview it so
i'm just going to preview it now
as you can see this will look like if
you share the link with anyone
we have a table we can also add trades
via the modals whether it's you know a
trade with two directions that will add
two lines
or just a custom trade i'll add one line
to
our table great
we have a few more things to do before
moving on um i can of course
or just add something here saying you
know
this is ania this is current user first
name so that will bring back anya as i
am the current user and my first name is
anya
or friend um i'm just going to get rid
of that let's not have or friend
that let's just have my name dashboard
okay even though technically maybe we
should have had or friend because if
there's no current user
and first name it will just say this is
dashboard
um but whatever this is fine
okay i can also make this uh
we don't have to just use the little
asterixes
i can use html in here too
so for example i can use h1 or let's
make this an
h2 tag and if i want to be more specific
with my styling
there is of course the option to add
more custom css
right here okay so you can really go to
town on the styling that is going to be
completely up
to you before finishing this let's
actually fix these
two um i guess the bar
chart and the pie chart as we said
changing the table uh column names seem
to broke this
so once again i'm just going to select
this graph right here
and i am simply just going to
as the data source i think probably the
easiest thing to do is just delete this
and then once again use the syntax the
retail syntax to get to the trades
and get all the data from the trades
wonderful
so that is there um you can't really see
it because it's very light and we did
add a trade with
a huge amount of commission
uh which of course is just being very
tall right now there we go so we've
added
a few of these wow
so that is why it's looking a bit
different a little bit better it's just
because
one has a very tall number
okay so once again this is what it is
looking
like wonderful
okay now let's go ahead and preview what
this looks like
on our custom-made url
and there we go here is our
custom dashboard just one more to do and
that is
the brokers because i can see that's not
reflecting correctly
so i'm just going to once again you
get rid of this data source type it in
again
okay so get trades data
let's hide the rest of these
okay and there we go so that is looking
way more correct
just based on the new trace that we
added which just had like a ridiculous
volume okay and that is it
hopefully you've learned a lot in this
first part
of the tutorial we have covered
quite a lot we've covered how to
essentially use
data from google sheets and also
learn how to integrate and also learn
how to integrate
slack api in order to create your own
custom dashboard
and of course customize the css as well
as a lot of other things
too now that we've covered this let's
move on to working with
rest apis in the next section i'll see
you there
okay now in this section we're gonna
learn how to build our own personal
crypto app using the queen api
and twilio api to send messages so let's
do it
the first thing i'm going to do is add a
resource i'm just going to click on
resources here
and create a new resource this is going
to be a rest
api so let's call this
coin api just like that
and now i'm going to find the api so
this is the api i'm going to use
for this tutorial we're going to have to
get a
key for this so we can actually use this
so i'm just
going to get a free api key
click here and to get my free api key
i'm just going to put in my
email address gmail.com
anya developer
and get a free api key so that should
now be emailed
to me let's check it out
and there we go we have our apr key
please
keep it safe so i'm just going to copy
this and now
in here this is where we're going to
have to put
our api key at the moment i am just
going to put it in the header
as a string
okay so make sure that is a string and
then let's get to the documentation to
see
what we should uh use as the key for
this
api key so i'm going to go back here we
don't need this anymore
and let's check out the api docs i will
be deactivating this key so
please do use your own um this will not
be valid anymore at the time
this tutorial goes live so here we go
here is everything that we need there is
a
bunch of different data here what i'm
going to get
for now uh i'm just going to get the
base urls we can use all of these
endpoints
in our app and i'm literally just going
to copy
let's copy the sandbox one actually so
sandbox
and i'm going to just put it here as the
base url
and then we need to find out what the
key
needs to go under so let's just have a
little scroll
there we go so this is what we're going
to have to have x
coin api key copy that
and once again as a string i'm just
going to paste it in
here so that is looking good this is all
we really need in order to be able to
communicate
with the coin api so i'm just going to
click
create resource great
and let's create an app using our korean
api
so i'm going to call this crypto dash
board create
wonderful so now we will see a queries
already been made
we have a little reminder for us on how
to use this base url that's really handy
please read the http docs
coin api for more information on how to
use this
api thank you very much so now that we
have that done
let's go to creating a table that's
going to list all the quotes for the
crypto currencies
so to do this i'm going to actually i
think we can shut this one down now
so i want to get the quotes so i'm
simply going to go here to get the
correct endpoint
and i can use this data right here
so this is what i'm going to get back if
i use this
get request i will get back
objects that look like this that have
you know a symbol
id exchange time exchange
so on so on and ask price a bid price
and everything else that we need
so i'm just going to copy this
just like that and then whack it in here
we don't need this extra one because we
have
the little dash here already
and now just to check this works let's
actually pick a
symbol id to filter by
so let's just say
this one
okay so you'll see here that was now url
parameter
and now we also need to put well that is
correct the x coin api key here again
and the headers
so i'm just going to get this and put it
in here we don't need to specify
we don't need to put it as a string
because it automatically gets converted
to a string
for us so now if we run this here
you will see the response which at the
moment isn't
coming back with anything perhaps this
needs to be a
okay well let's just get all the
currencies for now
and there we go here is our response we
have
managed to successfully get all that
data so we've got the data now let's put
it in the app
so that is our first query done we can
of course rename it let's rename it to
make this
more uh usable i'm going to call it
quotes
because that is what it is it's just the
quotes for all the prices
okay great
so now that we have that i'm just going
to perhaps make this a little bit
smaller like so and then let's just drag
in a table this is going to be super
painless
here is our table
and you'll see that it's already managed
to
sort of decide that this is what we want
so it's just picked out the first query
that we did
it's got the query here so the query is
quotes we've just called it quotes
and it's got all the data from our
quotes query
okay so i'm just going to move this
around
so you can see we've got symbol id time
exchange timecoin api ask price ask
size basically everything that we got in
the
response
here
wonderful so that is very intuitive we
really didn't have to do much
i'm actually going to show you how you
can personalize
this table so what if i don't really
like the way
that the api gave me all these keys i
don't want them as my table
headers so i can change them i can
simply go in here and call this symbol
id just like that
and then maybe let's change all of these
do we want the time exchange
we could just keep timecoin api so i can
also hide this one
um to do this i can
simply just click on this little i right
here and it disappears
timecoin api let's also rename this
time
coin api
and then i can also so this is quite
cool
i can say that the column type is
a date time original time zone which
will change it
to a date format for me
so that is pretty cool now the ask
price let's make that ask
price like so and then i'm actually
going to change this
to uh reflect a price more so let's
pick that from here we could use float
or we could use
uh us dollars if we want like so it's
totally up to us
okay so it could look like
this if we wish
um now let's do the ask size
oh yeah if you click on these it
automatically uh filters by this column
that's quite cool
so got the ask price now let's do the
ask
size just like that
and then maybe let's make this a float
so i'm going to make a float
okay so once again
that is looking good or you can make a
full integer
it's totally up to you
okay so we've done the ask size let's do
the bid price now
bid price
and then let's also make this us dollars
it would seem not many people are
trading on the ku coin spot
now let's also do the bid size so i'm
just going to change that here
to oops i want bid size so i'm going to
keep bid size i'm just going to rename
it
and once again i'm going to make this a
float
and then we should also probably have
last trade so i'm going to have last
trade too
now this is interesting because we're
going to have to this is an object
so we're going to have to learn how to
work with that object
because we don't want this to appear
like this we actually want to go into
the object to get a value so let's do
that
so to do this i would use the mapper and
i'm going to use
the keyword self so that it knows i'm
talking about
that particular uh component and then
i'm going to go into the object
and pick out the time coin api it's
quite nice that these are auto
populating for me
the time coin api so now if i look here
you will see that that is exactly what's
been picked out for the last trade
i've essentially let's have a look at
the request and the response sorry the
response
so i've gone this is what it was
returned to me for last trade and that's
what i was trying to put in each cell
but i said no i want the last trades
timecoin api
okay so hopefully that makes
sense now let's also perhaps format this
to be
a date so date
let's say original time zone
wonderful okay
so this is looking really good
you can of course also move them around
so perhaps maybe let's use
move the bid size
then the bid price so the bid and the
ask are
you know next to each other and that is
looking
great wonderful
now i can of course also personalize
this
further if i want i can
add a color so background color um
for this you can just type red
or green or you can be more specific and
put in hex colors too the choice is
completely
up to you but i'm quite happy with this
looking the way it is
right now it's already come with
pagination for us which is really useful
i just want to do one more thing and
that is add an option for us to be able
to
search so essentially we want to be able
to filter out
so filter by the symbol id
okay so i'm just going to do that up
here
so to do this i'm actually going to find
a component that is a text
input so i'm just going to
grab that and whack it here i'm going to
make it a little bit
longer and let's change the label to say
search like so and then i'm going to
actually leave a placeholder too so for
example
enter symbol id
okay so we've done that of course at the
moment it's not really linked up to
anything so that is our next job let's
get to linking this
up so that it works to do this i want
you to go back to my quote
i'm just going to make this a little bit
bigger so remember at the beginning we
tried to
filter so we used this because we were
trying to filter by
symbol id so
i'm essentially going to bring that back
in but instead of filter id
like this i am going to essentially
just going to get rid of that so i'm
going to use
this syntax i am going to
find the text input one
text input one so i'm literally finding
this component i'm reading the blue off
it
so i know that this component is called
text input one
for this platform and i'm just gonna get
the
value okay so now whatever i type into
this is essentially going to be
this and
now i just need to make this uh trigger
on change
so we need an event handler for this the
event handler is going to be a
change because we're not submitting
anything i just wanted to change as i
type
and it's going to trigger the query and
that is going to be the
quotes query
okay so that is the event that's going
to trigger
as soon as i start typing like so
so i've just searched by
uh symbol and you will see all these
symbols with btc have been filtered
i can of course go let's just maybe type
gemini spot btc
sgt gemini spot and let's see if it's
changing
okay so that is changing it's got
anything would gem a nice spot
here now brilliant
this is looking really cool
just gonna go maybe change this back to
btc for now
wonderful
okay so now we've got our quotes coming
through
and our search is working let's carry on
the next thing i want to do is just get
all the main
cryptocurrencies that i want to i guess
monitor
in another table right here so
let's go ahead and do that for this i'm
actually going to
and make a new query but using the same
api
so let's use the resource query
i'm going to make this bigger for us and
this query i'm just going to call
currencies
it's got quotes we've got currencies and
for this one
well i just want to get a few uh
currencies with their little images so i
know that this exists here because i've
had a look at this before
the end point i want for to get all to
essentially filter out
specific cryptocurrencies that i want
but also include all their assets and
stuff
um is let's have a look
here we go assets but also filtered by
certain coins
so i'm gonna grab this one and i'm just
gonna whack it in here
so v1 assets filter asset and let's what
shall we get
i want to get well let's get bitcoin
let's also get ethereum maybe
uh i'm just gonna put a few
in here
um maybe
okay so i'm literally just using the
documentation here
and i know this is what is going to be
returned okay
so that is what is going to happen let's
save and run
ah yes we also need to put in the api
key again so once again just in the
header section
and what was this called oops
so paste that in here save it
and then we also need this one
and save and run
okay so now if we look at the response
wonderful okay so we're getting the
uh bitcoin the litecoin the tether coin
doji coin ethereum finance coin
cardano coin and die i don't really know
what that one is but it was
on there so i just put it in as well
okay
so we filtered out just a few from the
api the next thing i want to
do is use this id coin to get an image
but first of all let's just whack them
in a table so once
again i'm just going to drag a table
across
super easy and it's pretty much guess
that that's the one we
want i think it's because we are on it
we're selected on it so it naturally
just goes to that one
it's getting the currencies query
and they're giving me the data from it
um if you want to see more of these
what exactly these come back with so
here you see currencies and that is the
data so we're getting all the currencies
data
and then you can go further into each
object in the data array too so that is
essentially just the response but maybe
a bit more workable
uh in terms of being a developer and
wanting to get the correct properties
from the response okay so that is
i just got that by clicking this left
panel right here
i'm going to minimize it for now but um
if you ever want to see it it's just
it's just right there cool
so now we have our most popular
or the ones we chose sorry the the our
chosen cryptos that we want to keep an
eye on
let's get to personalizing this table a
bit more again
so for this one i'm actually just going
to
okay yeah let's keep the asset id
i want that that is fine type crypto i
mean we sort of know that so i'm gonna
get rid of that
uh i don't want this i don't want this
i do want the name let's perhaps switch
this around though i'm going to put
name
i actually don't want a bunch of this
stuff i really only care about
the volume one day usd and the price
so just delete or hide sorry deletes
probably the wrong word
so let's use this one volume
one day u.s dollar and then let's change
this to of course
us dollar oh
and then the price usd i'm just going to
put price
and then make sure that there's taller
so
okay and now the icon i want the icon to
be at the beginning
okay great so we've done that before i
actually get to
putting the images in using a
um we're going to do a little bit of
javascript for that
i'm actually going to now show you how
to put in
twilio's api in order to send a text
message
to your friends and family from this
platform
so i think uh yeah let's let's do it
so to do this i'm actually going to go
back to my resources page
and i'm going to create new and this
time
let's actually search for twilio so
twilio is one of the apis that comes
already sort of
with uh retool as a resource you can of
course
you know um get in touch with them if
there's something that's missing
but luckily twilio is here so let's just
go ahead and click it
and i'm gonna call this just twilio
api twilio 1l
okay so now let's go to twilio i don't
really want this
anymore for now let's go to twilio
i'm just going to click here and sign
up for a twilio account so i can get a
twilio api
so anyhow
and what is it asking us for it's asking
us for an account sid and an auth token
so let's go ahead and find that
and now i want to use the sms
service and i'm just building
i guess what's the most
alerts and notifications how do you want
to do this
i don't know with code with a minimal
code
let's do with minimal code okay
javascript
get started perfect so we've got an
account sid
i'm just going to take that and whack it
in here
and then the auto can show once again i
won't
this won't be active so please do use
your own um
when doing this tutorial these will not
work any
more and then just create resource
wonderful so that is it uh back to
resources i don't want to create a new
app
so we have our twilio api
ready let's actually shut these down
because we are done now
with those and let's go back here and
i'm just going to click import from
query library
and then i'm just going to find
the twilio api wonderful
so we've done that and the next thing i
want to do is actually create
a form
okay so this form is uh
essentially where
uh i am going to send text messages from
so let's go ahead and maybe make this a
little bit
nicer so i can essentially drag
items in here i'm going to drag
some text and in here
i'm just going to say send a text quick
so using
send a text
quick so this is to make it bold and we
don't need this anymore
perhaps we'll put in an emoji though
anyway they are quite fun
so i'm going to put in a little mobile
phone
there we go
wonderful so we've got some text and now
let's actually put in some inputs so i
need the input because i need to know
exactly who i'm going to text so i'm
gonna maybe put in this
number input let's use the number input
maybe this won't really be the best
one no let's not use this one
so i'm just gonna delete that one
let's just use the text input
just because i don't want to select a
number i actually want to put in quite a
long number
so let's put phone number here
okay you can of course you can style
this up however
you wish you can position it like this
i think that looks maybe a little bit
better so we've got off uh
phone number here the next thing i want
to do
let's make this
does that look okay i mean you can you
can go wild okay it's
going to be totally up to you how you
want this to look
you can spend hours styling up i don't
want this to be about styling i want it
to be about
you know getting getting the job done
and then styling afterwards
so we've got that the next thing i'm
going to do is just put in a text input
below here and this is going to be for
the actual
message itself so perhaps maybe there's
a better one than this
um
ah let's maybe use this different one
okay i'm gonna delete that
you can use a bigger one as well we can
use a text area which i think i prefer
so let's use the text area
again just pull out the top
and once again let's maybe call this
message i can just spell message
message and then
enter value or enter text
it is up to you
okay so i think this is
looking good we can have this as a
required field so let's make this a
required field
and then you can do a bunch of other
stuff too to really sort of personalize
the whole thing
okay so now that we have that maybe
let's make this a little bit
smaller now wonderful
so now let's get to hooking it up so
we're going to do this
with these two values so
fast off i'm actually just going to
change the color of this just because i
can
so this is how you do something like
that we can change the button color
to whatever color we wish now
so we have the twilio api okay
so i essentially want to post
to my twilio api so let's get the docs
out again
so let's carry on with this so we've got
our cid we've got
all talk token let's get a trial
number so this is going to be our trial
number
choose this number
okay so this is now a new phone number
i'm just going to make a note of this
and done okay
so now that we have that we need to
figure out how we're going to use this
in order to send text messages
so i'm going to get the quick start docs
and then just go to node.js
twilio rest api so this is the request
that we're going to have to
make that makes sense
api operation oh it's already done it
for us
uh that's really handy so i want to post
so this is for addresses
i just want the one for messages
so there's a lot in here but i'm just
impressed that um
retool already had this i pretty much
didn't really need to view the
messages at all so messages
messages messages
message is jason okay
got it okay so now in here
well we already have um the
account sid we've already done that part
so 2.
2 is going to be the text input so i'm
going to grab text input 2 once again
this is how we would do it in here
i'm going to grab text input 2 and get
its
value and that's the 2
and then the body
so i'm just going to get the body of
text area 1
text area
1
value okay and then the
from
we're gonna have to have a from which
isn't actually on here
but that's fine we're gonna add it
now so from
and then here's where i'm gonna put my
saved
new phone number because this is gonna
be my twilio phone number
so just like that okay
and let's try it out so i'm just going
to save that
let's rename this to send
text
and i'm just going to put in my phone
number into here as a test
using the country code that i'm in
hello me
and at the moment the submit button
isn't really hooked up but if i run this
that should work
so query around successfully i'm just
going to wait for my
text i got a text
can you see that pretty cool
okay nice so we've done that that works
let's actually instead of me running it
here manually
i want it to run if i click the submit
button so let's click on the submit
button
here and i'm just going to have to add
an event listener
or an event handler sorry and it's going
to be the query send text
that is correct i am happy with that
sentex trigger
and i can also do things like send
confetti
so when the submit happens i can
just send some confetti so let's try
that again
hello me submit confetti's run
comment is i guess thrown at us what's
the trigger when the buzzing
has been clicked okay cool and once
again let's check out that as well it's
how i got a text
wonderful i've got another text
amazing so that is how we would link up
the
twilio uh api and how we would
link it up to this text input and this
text input
and make it run when we click the submit
button
so this is looking pretty good we've got
our crypto dashboard
we can filter this table right here we
also have a separate table here for
uh crypto coins that we specifically
wanted to keep an eye on
and we can send a text using
the twitter's api directly from our
platform
now one last thing um we can of course
you know personalize this
load i can make a beautiful header if i
want to
um so you can just call this
i don't know let's call it my crypto
dashboard it's completely
up to you how you would like to
do this so perhaps yeah maybe let's
style it up a little bit just while we
are here
let's put in some text
so again if i want to use my current
name i can use current user
and the first name uh or if that doesn't
exist it'll just say hello
friend that's exactly what this code is
saying i'm going to say
welcome anya or friend
to your crypto
so just
like so
there we go
great okay so the last thing we'll do is
actually
use the icons here and this is going to
involve some i guess
advanced uh coding i say advanced a
little bit more advanced than what we're
doing now
so what i want to do is essentially use
these id
icons to get an image so let's go ahead
and do that now
the first thing i'm going to do is
actually create a new
query resource query using the coin api
so let's go back to the coin api
documentation because i want to get the
images
so coin api
and then general here
get all asset icons that's what i want i
want the asset
icons for this so to do this i would
simply get the asset icons
there we go here we go uh i can get
these and i could just pass through an
icon size two
so i'm gonna copy this mac that in here
and let's make them 32 pixels
so once again however i'm going to have
to
get the
api key and then
just work that in here too and click
save and run
let's rename this query to images just
so it's more readable
and now the queer comes back with all
of our images as well as the as well as
the asset id
so if i was just to grab this and then
just paste it
in the url you will get the asset
wonderful
so we've got that now we need to
essentially
uh put the icon url sort of in here
based on the asset id
so we're going to have to add some
javascript to do this to pass the images
so i'm just going to click here and i'm
actually going to create a custom column
that i'm going to call
icon okay
and in here i'm just going to use an
image tag like so
a closing image tag and i'm going to use
low dash here
so the source for this is going to be
this is obviously for my
retool syntax i'm going to use find
this isn't a javascript tutorial so i'm
just going to provide you with a code
i'm going to get the images data and
then that's the first parameter and the
second parameter is going to be a
function
so the function is going to have
i'm just going to pass through o for
object and then open up the curly braces
and return o asset
id equals
current row so current row of this table
asset id okay
so there we go and then
just do dot euro
nice and obviously let's make sure that
this is a string
so
okay so now i'm just gonna actually move
this custom one right here
hide this icon
and we need to render this as pure html
and there we go so now that we have
rendered those as html that has now
worked we're getting all the icons show
up pretty neat
okay so now we can also preview this so
this is what our app will
look like
and wonderful brilliant i'm really happy
with that
the header is sticky everything else is
pretty responsive
and i can share this via this url to
whoever i
wish awesome so that is our crypto app
hopefully you found this useful and can
now
create your own crypto apps too using
the coin api
twilio api and retool i'll see you in
the next
lesson
okay so in this part we're going to
learn how to create an invoice tracker
using a graphql
api as well as learn how to embed videos
into the platform
so let's do it for this i'm gonna have
to start a database
i like to use data stacks so i'm just
going to
log in there i'm going to click on data
stacks
and i'm just going to click try for free
okay now i've already created an account
so i'm just going to click
here and just select an account to work
with
great so when i'm here i'm going to
create a new database
and then i'm just going to get started
clicking the get started button
and what should we call our database
let's call it
in boy says and the key space name
is going to be invoice says
key space just making it super easy for
you to follow along
with okay
and then i'm going to select europe
because i'm in europe
and just creates a database easy
okay so once we are here we just have to
wait for this status
to connect at the moment it's pending
i'm probably going to cut this out so
okay so the status is now active let's
go ahead and click
here so this is important we're going to
have to have
all of this information but first let's
go ahead and connect to our graphql api
now this is essentially the urls that
we're going to use in order to
uh hook up the grakua api to our
platform
so i am just going to
select this right here and that's going
to open up our playground
however we need to get our
api key or cassandra token so this is
what it looks like
we're going to have to put it in here in
order to communicate with this
and communicate with it in our retool
app too
so i'm just going to go to settings
and then select admin user and generate
the token
so here we go here is our token i'm just
going to copy
that please do make a note of it
somewhere
just to make things easier and to
communicate with this playground i would
just
click that like so so that is looking
good that works
we've proven it works so now let's go
back to our retool app
i'm just going to get rid of this and
let's create a resource
so this resource create new
i'm going to search for the graphql api
and in the headers this time i'm going
to put this token
as a string and then
here it's going to say
cassandra token i'm just going to paste
it like
so and then the url the base url for
this
well it's not going to be this it's
actually going to be
so if you go back here
to the documentation
graphql
it's going to be the invoice key space
but the first thing we need to do
is actually create some data
okay so let's just put this in there for
now so this is the url that we want to
be able to interact with
so i'm just going to put that as the
base url like so
and then i'm just going to
[Music]
let's name this graph
ql invoices
and create resource
okay so now that we've done that let's
create an app
i'm going to call this invoice
tracker like so
so now we're connected to our database
we're actually connected to the database
key space okay because we use the url
for the key space but there's nothing in
there
yet so there's two things we're going to
do with this
we're actually going to make our app
retrieve data but also
add data through the app too
just to get started though i'm just
going to put some dummy data
into our database first so i'm going to
do this using some mutations
so back here under the schema i'm
actually going to create a
table it's going to be mutation
and this is going to be called in voices
create a table for the invoices
open up some oops
i do actually want that so the key space
name well we know this is
invoices
key space
the table name is going to be
i'm just going to call it invoices
and we need to give some partition keys
i'm going to have it as
this is going to be
an id and the id is actually going to be
a string
so type basic
text for the id now the values
that are going to be allowed are going
to be
named
which is also going to have a type
of basic text
just space this out a little bit maybe
we're also going to have a
value of the invoice which is going to
be a
float so the id is essentially the
invoice ideal reference the company name
is obviously just a company name string
the value is going to be the value of
the invoice
uh we're also going to have a paid or
not paid which is going to be a boolean
and we're going to have a timestamp
which is actually going to be a text
there is
like a time stamp but i'm just going to
do text just to make our lives a bit
easier
okay and just click
done so we've run that we've created a
table the table name is invoices
and it has an id a company a value a
paid or not paid and a timestamp
wonderful so we've created a table now
let's get to adding an
invoice into our table so for this we
can now use the
docs
i'm going to have to
go to this url again
okay so i'm just going to replace this
with that url
and i'm going to get to the cassandra
token again so we can
talk to our key space
and then i'm just going to write a
mutation to add an
invoice so insert invoices that's what
we want
so it's going to be mutation
and and then invoices so you can go like
invoice
one for example
and then insert invoices
and now i'm just going to have the value
so what did we have in here again where
we had
the id
we can actually just see these here so
id
as a string uh we're gonna have invoice
o
one and then we're also gonna have
company which is also a string
let's go aunt bessie's
cup cakes limited
i'm just going to space this out so you
can see
paid true
time stamp let's leave that for now
value and we'll have this is a float
so let's do 201
okay and the time stamp took us to
today's
time stamp
so we're going to use the iso one
i'm just going to put it as a string
okay and then let's make it
maybe a month back just like so
so there's one invoice let's see if that
works
and then i'm just actually going to
so those are our values
and then let's just return the values
idea from works
okay so that has worked we've added one
invoice while i'm here let's just add a
few
so i'll just make this zero two ah
zero two this is going to be motley
cruise
paid true and then this make this
the tenth the value is going to be for
i don't know this much
add that again um i'm not going to add a
lot i'm just going to do this for
obviously like demonstration purposes so
maybe let's add like
just one more
for now um
who else can we have heist
heracle
minted paid let's do this one as false
and then let's make this the 14th the
value is going to be for
cool so we've got three invoices in
there let's just do one more
um just because i want to
and yeah historical id again maybe
and then
fifth okay so we've got four invoices in
our
database at the moment let's see if we
can get them
into our app before we start adding
stuff to our database from the app
so i'm going to go back here
let's delete that one we don't want this
one i'm going to create new
resource query and this time i'm going
to use the graphql api
and now i need to retrieve my data
so i know how to do this if you want to
use the documentation just refer back to
this
i need to get all the data
and that will look
like this query but we need to get all
of them so
we could just write our own in the
graphql playground and see if it works
so i'm just going to comma that out for
now
and use the docs so if i want to get all
the invoices
it's going to be a query
and then invoices
id value
time stamp what should we have company
and then paid
wonderful so this is the correct query
to get all four of our
invoices i'm just going to copy it
and then just put it in
now the url it's asking me for the url
again
no worries though i'm just going to copy
this here
seems like we didn't get the correct ah
we want this one
yeah okay so i'm just going to change
this to be the one we pre-made
okay wonderful
you can of course just create one from
here too but as we've already made it
i'm gonna use this one right here
and just click save and run
and great
so we now have all our four invoices
ready to use
for our app so the nice thing about this
here is you can actually see the queries
and mutations available to you
so it's taken them directly from the
docs in the
playground that have been generated for
us
great so now that we have that
i'm just going to actually delete this
and then let's make a new table but
using this new
query that we just have
okay so i'm going to rename this to
something
let's call this graph ql
invoices okay
so now instead of this data like this so
this is some like
default data i don't want this we're
gonna have to use our query
so we're gonna get the graphql invoices
data just like that
and now this is a great time for using
this because that's obviously not
working that's not enough we need to get
the data
but then we also need to get the
invoices and then we also need to get
these values
so i'm going to do invoices
and then values and wonderful
so we now have thanks to our little left
sidebar we now have all the four
invoices in our dashboard
that we need great
just gonna make this a little bit bigger
okay so let's carry on
once again maybe let's do some
[Music]
uh personalization so i'm going to
change this to invoice
reference just to be super clear about
what that is
this value well i think value should be
fine but maybe let's make it us
dollars so i'm just going to choose
dollars and the timestamp i'm just going
to change this maybe to the
date so i'm just going to change this to
date and then use the date
original time zone to change that into
a date format which is easier for us to
read
company i'm happy with company maybe
let's just make it like a capital
c
and this paid so i can change this to a
check box
great and now these are the ones are
paid and these are the ones that aren't
paid but we want to be able to edit this
right so we'll do that
in a bit i'm just gonna maybe make this
smaller again
before we move on i'm actually just
gonna show you how to create
uh headers that aren't i guess tied to
the top so to do that
obviously we're in the header now that
is not correct i'm going to move this
down to the main section
i don't really want anything in the
header this time
because i don't want the header to
essentially appear on the published
app so by leaving it blank that's
exactly what will happen
so this time i'm going to actually just
make a container
make around this big and i can change
the color of this
container if i wish i can make it like
this greeny color
oops it's greeny color cool
and then in here i'm just going to
essentially
uh put in maybe like an invoice tracker
so i want a title
let's put in a title
and as the value i could just use html
like this
and put invoice tracker
okay and that will work too
invoice
and then maybe let's put some more text
here
hello anya or friend
this is your custom invoice
tracker
i mean there's really a bunch of stuff
we can do we can add an
image if we want to put in a little
image of an
invoice
so then i can just simply select this
and then i actually have some images on
my imager which i like to store so i'm
just going to use that
okay so that is an image from my imager
and i'm just going to replace that
url like so
so we've now got a title this is what it
looks like if you preview the app and
you want to share it via the url
so you see the other headers now gone
that is the main
header okay let's go back to editing the
app
now we can actually create
things super easily just by dragging and
dropping
charts so if i want to create a chart i
would simply drop this in
here and then it's going to get my
graphql invoice data
now we can be really specific about what
kind of data we want to feed into this
graph so let's do it
once again going into data is not enough
we need to go into the invoices
and get the values
okay so just like for the table we need
to be a bit more precise
so now it's done by invoice and value
however what if we don't want this what
if we want to do it by
value and date so we can easily do that
i would simply have to just change the
x-axis
values so at the moment's id i can
choose
timestamp and it really is that easy
okay so i can put value here instead
and at the bottom i could put
date okay um
obviously oops
i might have to make that a little bit
better in order to see that
in a nicer way
okay
so we've now created a graph to let us
know
what days we made the most money on you
can edit this way further like say i
want to
change the color of this i can of course
do that
too wonderful
so the next thing i want to do is
actually also maybe create a pie chart
so let's go ahead and do that i'm going
to show you how to create a pie chart
grab that here and this time i'm going
to just select pie chart once again i
need to go into the
invoices values
and great again i if i don't want this
to
do it by invoice by id i can
change it up so to do this um
maybe again let's
do this by
okay i want to change the colors though
so i could just go around and change a
bunch of colors if i wish
again we're not gonna um
be splitting it by these so let's change
that let's do it by paid or not paid
so the green is how many haven't paid
for invoices
and this is how many been paid so that's
quite a good statistic
i think that's quite a good one to keep
there
and i could also do things like put
these in containers
so let's maybe do that just to make it
look a bit nicer
so i'm going to grab a container
i'm going to stick this in the container
okay and now i can put a title or just
some text that will look like it's
part of the
same container so if i do this and i
just put
let's make this maybe an h
three tag this time
and root paid versus unpaid
and then maybe just make sure that it's
in the
middle okay cool
um we can of course put more things in
this container if we wish so maybe let's
go ahead and do that
uh it's totally up to you we can even do
whoops
we can even put in another graph maybe
to so
show how many clients have given the
most
money so once again
we will need to go into the data
invoice values
to get that data and this time
let's do it by company so now we can see
which
company has essentially
given us the most money and again maybe
let's change that to a different
color wonderful
okay so this is starting to shape up
really
nicely uh
maybe let's move that a bit further
oops down here just so we have a bit
more space for these things we don't
need to squish them all up
for example i actually want to put a
video up here
so i'm just going to make some space for
that to happen
let's give this a title too so i can do
invoices
by value maybe let's get rid of this one
and then also give this one a title so
this should be
paid versus on
paid versus paid versus on
page
okay i'm gonna stick this
table up here
move this container down a bit
and just elongate that just in case we
get more
invoices coming through
okay
so now i'm going to show you how you can
also embed uh
videos if you wish so
for this i'm just going to maybe let's
also give it a title
have you
done your tax return so sort of like a
reminder if you're managing
these platforms right and a lot of
people are using them
you might want to remind them to do
something that is important
so have you done your tax return and
then maybe let's
uh i don't know what we want to do with
this
i actually don't like the way this looks
so let's get rid of that and i'm going
to use a
text instead so i'm going to put some
text
in just like so
[Music]
and then make it centered um
let's make this like an h maybe just a
paragraph
let's have a play around
you can of course edit these even more
uh that's the beauty of
this low code platform okay so have you
done your tax return and then let's put
in a video
so to add a video i would simply just
drag this in here so i'm just going to
put it in here
and i'm just going to
[Music]
i mean yeah that's a great video but
maybe you should do something that is
to do with taxes so you can obviously
put your own video i'm just going to use
one of youtube
tax return us just because we are
dealing with
dollars so let's
just give a video
on that this is from 2020
but i mean i know we're in 2021 but
i'm just gonna use this one
just so you can see what that whoops
looks like
i need to get this let's get the url
and just put it in there okay wonderful
so this is looking really good let's
preview what this looks like
on
the app
okay so this is what you would look like
it would look like to anyone that you
shared it with
looking awesome very minimal we did very
minimal stuff to it you can of course
style this up as much as you want
all the components come already pre-made
you can
style them up uh with just by changing
colors
or text or you can go that little bit
further
uh by changing the css just like we did
in the first
video okay one more thing to do
and that is i'm going to show you how to
add an invoice
and also update an invoice
let's get things going by creating a new
resource
query this time i'm just going to make
this
bigger so this time we need to figure
out a way to actually
add data to our
database so to do this let's first off
practice
in our playground so i'm just going to
comment this out
and then write a mutation using the docs
provided
in order to insert a new invoice so
i'm just going to essentially use these
docs to help me
we are going to be writing a mutation if
you're not super well-versed in gracky
well i would recommend of course doing a
tutorial previously on it as this is not
a graphql tutorial
this is a low code tutorial for those
you know who already have some
graphql knowledge but of course please
don't let that stop you
let's carry on so for this mutation to
create a new invoice
i would simply need to create mutation
which is going to look like this
this invoice is going to be 0 5 and i'm
just going to put
insert invoices and in
here the values that i need
to essentially create my invoice
so the value for this
is gonna be id invoice zero zero five as
a string and then i'm gonna have
the uh float of 10.01
a time stamp which i'm just going to use
as a
string just to make our lives a lot
easier
so i'm just going to use this format
here and perhaps let's change things
up a little bit maybe let's just change
this to 15. okay just to
mix it up a bit so we've got the id
we've got the value we've got the
timestamp next we need company unpaid
so let's say a company
let's write company and then of course
this is gonna be a string so
i'm just gonna put um let's put
uh any there you go limited
and is abacus is limited fine is that
how you spell abacuses
oh i don't even know anya's and eater
missions limited okay let's move on
uh unpaid this is gonna be a boolean as
we said and i'm gonna say
false okay so this is how i would expect
the mutation would look like if i was to
create a new one but
let's check it out so
let's go ahead and run it ah validation
error
sub selection request
set invoices all right okay
we need to return something so let's
just return um
some values and i'm just going to attend
an id just to see if it works
okay wonderful and that has
worked so we know this is the mutation
we need
so let's grab it and use it
so i'm just gonna go back to
i'm gonna just copy this actually first
back to here
and on this query i'm just gonna paste
this
in here like so okay we know this is the
mutation
we know this works but we now need to
replace
all the uh the id the value the times
that the company
and paid with stuff from our platform
okay so for this maybe let's just
let's just check it works from this here
this platform actually here too
let's change this to invoice six and
verse six
um let's change the value i'm gonna
change the timestamp
uh and let's just save this and run it
just to check again
okay that has worked our response is um
our query has run successfully we've got
a response
so this query works let's rename this to
add invoice to make it more readable
okay and now let's get to replacing all
the values with stuff
from our platform so
how are we going to do this we need to
replace all these
values we'll probably make a model um
we're gonna have to have an id this is a
string
as we said has to be a string
okay so just like that and i'm going to
replace
whatever we pass through this as the id
next we need the
company and the company is also going to
be a string
so let's replace whatever we pass
through here as
the company
great we've got the id we've got the
company let's
do the uh time stamp next
and this is also going to be a string
we've chosen this to be a string
just for this demo and there we go
time stamp okay now let's move on to the
value
the value is going to be a float
remember
um so we're going to have to put float
for that
and then we're going to just grab the
value and replace it
here so whatever we pass through the
value is going to be the value
and that's it oh no we also need to pay
it
and paid is going to be a boolean
and then we're going to replace paid
with page
wonderful and this i'm just going to
have as id it doesn't really
matter okay
great so we are sort of there
now our variables have generated for us
below
based on what we have just
written most recently so now
i think it's time to essentially create
our model
okay so to
create a new invoice
i am gonna have to just like we did if
you remember
in the first tutorial with creating
uh traits i'm going to do the same
so let's grab our not
button we need a middle drag it down
here
let's perhaps rename this to add
invoice oops invoice
okay and now
let's get it maybe do you want to give
it a
let's change the button to be red why
not
or maybe green green is less uh angry
okay so we've got our model let's start
dragging stuff into the module
so for this i am going to essentially
put in all the inputs that we need to
create an invoice
so this will include everything we have
just uh i guess
stated are our variables so let's do our
first one i'm going to drag in a text
input
and then i'm going to put a placeholder
placeholder of
enter invoice reference this is going to
be essentially the id of the
invoice okay so there we go
invoice reference the next thing we need
is this time again let's actually have a
text
input and then this is going to be let's
make this the company
so label company
name and then let's have
another text input
for the timestamp
or actually no let's not have that let's
actually make a date selection for this
so i'm going to change this to
um let's change this to invoice amount
oh no let's make this let's get rid of
this actually and make
a usernumber input instead
let's get the number input this time
i'm just going to drag it in here let's
change the label
let's make the label say
invoice amount
great and i'm just going to delete this
using my keyboard commands
okay so that is now gone
so we have the image reference we have
the company name we have the invoice
amount what else do we need
we need the ah actually
there's another one we can use okay
let's use the currency one so i'm just
going to drag that in here and once
again
invoice amount and then once again use
my keyboard to delete
that one so now we now got a currency
one that's formatted to take
currency okay that makes a lot more
sense the numbers now will come in
currency
format wonderful
okay now
we need to
now let's pick the date time
picker so i'm just going to search date
picker
and grab that and just whack it in
to here okay just like that
and now we have a date selector
so i'm going to use this for my
timestamp essentially to carry on
the next thing i need to do is the paid
or not paid so as this is a boolean i'm
simply going to look for a checkbox
so i'm going to use this right here and
just write
page question mark easy
so that is now it um
let's maybe add some text to make it
really obvious to the user what this is
for i'm just going to drag that in
and put add a new invoice
there we go add a new invoice just as a
title
right here it doesn't look super great
of course we can edit it i can
center this if i want just to make
things a look
a lot nicer so there we go
cool i'm just going to move these down a
little bit just to make it
a little bit more spaced out and just i
think
look better in general okay
so the next thing we need to do is
actually make something happen once it's
filled out
and for this i'm going to use a button
in the previous tutorials i did make a
form
in this one i'm going to show you how to
do without form so i'm just going to use
a button
instead to essentially trigger a query
if all the values are
filled out
so let's go back in here and now that we
have our variables
i'm going to use the retool syntax to
pick out components and their values
as the variables so for the id
well we know that the text input
one here the value is going to be the
id of the invoice so i'm going to grab
text input one
value okay you'll see the blue text
showing up that is the component's
name okay next we do the company
so this is going to be text input choose
value the timestamp which is going to be
the number input value
okay or i think it is number input value
maybe it's not number input
number input number input
and one is not defined okay so let's go
back here and just double check
that now that is the invoice
type number invo number two value is
the uh value of the invoice okay
and this is date picker one
fine so date picker one is going to be
the timestamp let's copy
let's cut that out sorry and put it
under value and this is going to be date
picker date time date yeah that's the
one date time picker
let's format to string because we did
say that the time stamp needs to be a
string
cool and finally let's get the little
checkbox
so it's just checkbox one as you saw by
the
blue little writing great
okay so we've done it
we have picked out all the variables
that we need
based on the input values and now we
just need to
hook up the button to trigger this query
so essentially because we are on the
query already at
invoice this is sort of done for us the
query is add invoice
and if we click the button this will
trigger the query
okay great and just because i like it
i'm gonna put some confetti here too
if we click the button okay
so now let's save this and test it out
invoice reference
let's go ahead and put
um
okay so that's ran but obviously that we
didn't add anything because there's
nothing in here
so let's put invoice zero seven
company name i'm going to put
tony's turtlenecks
limited invoice amount
223 and let's pick a date
sure there we go and just select paid
and submit
so we have just submitted it we have
added
an invoice then that was that seems to
have worked
awesome query run successfully but we
won't
see it in our platform okay
this is because we need to run another
query after all this
is done we can do it let i'll show you
how we can do it here
in the event handlers so once this we
click this button
we essentially send an invoice we create
a new invoice
but i can also ask it to
get all my invoices again so i'm going
to run the graphql
invoices query that we previously wrote
so if we click it it will add an invoice
but also get all the invoices
so let's test that out let's add another
invoice
08 i'm just going to change the price
again and just change the
date and click submit
so now you will see here
amazing invoice 8 and invoice 7
are now visible in my table because the
graphql invoices query
has run if you remember from
my first tutorial you can also do it
on the query itself so after the query
round has run successfully
has run successfully it is totally up
to you okay whichever one works best for
what you are making
at that moment in time okay so this is
looking
fantastic i'm really pleased with how
far we have gotten
we have been able to get data from our
database but we're also now adding data
to our database from the platform itself
great and finally i'm going to show you
how to update an invoice
so for this i am once again going to
create
a new query let's just go
here resource query and let's rename
this to
update invoice just to be super clear
about what we are doing
now i'm just going to save that and i'm
actually going to just copy this
mutation
because essentially to update invoice we
have
this mutation right here i'm just going
to paste
that and then i'm just going to change
oops
just change this to say update invoice
instead of
insert invoice as per the graphql
playground documentation
okay so it's exactly the same apart from
your updating invoice not adding one
and now we need to actually pick out
the correct component values
for this so i want to pick out whatever
row i interact with
so to do this i'm going to grab the
table
table what is it table 1 table 1
i'm going to use something called record
update to do this
the record updates is actually a
property of the table
please feel free to mess around with it
it might seem quite complex for now as
it's probably not something you've come
across before
but just know that it's a property of
the table to update
rows and just pass through a
zero to make sure that we on the first
item of the array
and grab the id of whatever row
we are in okay and do the same for this
whatever row we are in we want to grab
the
company and
whatever row we are in we want to grab
the timestamp
and whatever row we're in we want to
grab the value
i'm also going to pass float the
value just to
make sure that it's accepted
in case anything goes wrong i just want
to
wrap it in a pass float as this has to
be
a float value and paid again let's
whatever row we are in we are grabbing
the paid value
okay so that is it let's
check it out i'm not sure why it's read
maybe when we say this will go away but
i'm
confident that this is the correct code
okay
now one more thing we actually need to
enable editing for all of these so
enable
enable enable enable
great and now we just need an event
handler so this time
i'm just going to choose the change
option and then trigger update
invoices okay
so let's run this i'm just going to
minimize
this click save and now
we need to do one more thing once we
update the invoice we also need to
run the graphql invoices query to
re-fetch
all the invoices so i'm going to do that
on success
so after the query has run and it's been
successful i want to get
all the invoices again so now let's try
out i'm just going to change this
and save changes
and great so that has worked that is
updated
wonderful everything is looking good
okay and we can see here the query has
run successfully
amazing okay and it's picked out invoice
three because that is the invoice that
we're on wonderful
now i can i could rename this to you
know get
invoices it would make a lot more sense
as that's what we are doing
and we might make much more sense with
what i've written below so add invoices
and update and voice that would be
better but you know then you'd have to
change
uh that everywhere you've used in the
app so for now i'm just going to get rid
of it and just keep it as
graphql invoices for now
okay wonderful and let's check our app
so this is what our app looks like it is
now
finished if i interact with one of these
and say the change you will see that
that has
worked everything is looking
good amazing okay and
it's also updating all the graphs are
dependent
on this data so the bar charts and the
pie charts
too okay so i hope
that video was useful we have now
completed
three low code solutions all very
different
or practicing a lot of different apis
and a lot of different techniques
so hopefully there was a lot for you to
take away from
this course next up
where to go next
okay so hopefully you've learned a lot
by building three completely different
financial apps
i try to make each tutorial very
different to really sort of maximize
your
potential for gaining knowledge now
if you're not particularly into
financial apps there's a bunch of other
stuff you can build
too if you go to the retool site you can
actually see a bunch of different
templates that
you can click on in order to get coding
straight away
using them as a template some great
examples are a custom
crm a admin panel
a stripe refund tool so you can imagine
you're just working
at a maybe small business and you need
to
figure out a way to allow everyone on
the team to
issue refunds quickly you can build a
stripe
refund tool that looks like this
other things you can build our own s3
file exporter
a github pr dashboard a firebase admin
panel
a customer success panel customer
support
tools inventory management an image
annotator a machine learning image
labeler and so so much
more the potential for this is really
quite large
and i hope you can have a go at creating
your own dashboards
today thanks so much for watching and
i'll see you
soon